قواهم خارقه رغم ان اسلحتهم متواضعه
ذهابهم حيوانات البريه
وتخشاهم الاسود المفترسه لكن العكس ليس
بصحيح انهم شعب المسائيه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
هنا في احدى المناطق الصحراويه بين كينيا
وتنزانيا يعيش شعب المصري
قرب بحيره تركنا ارتحلون بين الحين والاخر
وحتمت عليهم ظروف حياتهم الصعبه مصارعه
جميعها المخاطر حتى لو كانت الاسود
المفترسه
في وجودهم لا يهنئوا اسد بفريسته
فالطبيعيه هو فرار البشري من الحيوانات
المفترسه لكن هنا المعادله اختلفت حيث تفر
الاسود والضباع من رجال المساج رغم ان
اسلحتهم متواضعه لا تتعدى رمحا وسكنا ولده
اسد
نافقواهم الخارقه تجعل حتى اشرس حيوانات
البريه تهامهم
طلبوا زواجي لدى شعب المسايه ليس كغيره
لدى باقي الشعوب قديما كان هناك تقليد خاص
لمعرفه قوه الشاب وشجاعته فبينما يصطففنا
الفتيات للمراقبه يخرج الفتيه الى الصحراء
لمقارعه اسد شارد وقطع راسه ثم العوده بها
الى كبير القوم وهذه القفزه لهذا دلاله
على مدى رشاقتهم ومن هنا يبدا اعجاب
الفتيات اما الحضوه فتكون من نصيب الشاب
الاقوى الذي يستطيع صرع الاسد لوحده
يقاربوا تعداد الشعب المصري المليون نسمه
الاغلبيه منهم تعيش بين شرق تنزانيا في
اقليم اروشا ومقاطعه في ناروتو غرب كينيا
ويتحدثون باللغه السواحليه فقط
مبارزه الاسود ليست الشيء الوحيد الذي
يميز الشعب المسائيه
فكبيرهم مثلا يستطيع الزواج بسبعين امراه
ربما اكثر اما الابقار لديهم فتعتبروا
عمله صعبه فمن خلالها يتم دفعه ظهور
الزواج كما قد تحل النزاعات والخلافات
بينهم بفديه من رؤوس الابقار
ما اعتقد من الحضري حاول شعب المساء
تقريبا بين قديم تراثهم وجديد تطلعاتهم
بالرغم من انهم حتى الان يبتغون للتمدن
سبيل وتراث اجدادهم الباقي يرفضون التفريط
او التهاون في تفاصيله العقيقه قوتهم في
باس معيشتهم وردهما الذي لا يتوقف خلف
اسود الغابه معادله يصعب على البشر فهمها
اسد جائع وشاب يصارع للحفاظ على هويه
اجداده